il a fait carrière comme représentant
dans les télécommunications
mais depuis deux semaines il enfile de
nouveaux habits entreprend une nouvelle
carrière celle de préposés aux
bénéficiaires pendant sa formation
pratique il était jumelé à une préposée
d'expérience marie soeurette thomas or
lose il était vraiment doué et est
dynamique il avait sa place après sa
formation il décide de rester mais si on
lui offre plus d'argent dans son ancien
domaine est souvent satisfait les larmes
aux yeux la nahia un sens du devoir
accompli je me sens utile chaque je fais
une différence et ses faux parents te
fait vraiment du prieuré incroyable il a
déjà tissé des liens avec des résidents
comme christian et ce sans avoir à leur
champion dans lanaudière environ 450
préposés ont suivi la formation abrégé
lancé en juin pour l'ensemble du québec
7115 personnes ont suivi cette formation
des gens sélectionnés parmi près de cent
mille candidats
en général les gens mais dieu cellphone
les courtes que vous avez séduit bon
candidat c'est déjà intéressant pose des
questions pertinentes aux sabots les
équipes en place sont soulagés par
l'arrivée de sang neuf
- temps de supplémentaires et puis les
résidents plus de soin et puis fait des
communications dialoguer beaucoup avec
les les résidents n'a plus de temps pour
les résidents de les voir un bon service
avec nos jours et paolo dit avoir trouvé
sa vocation des probables donner un peu
de dignité ces gens alors de le faire
d'une façon ce qu'ils sentent pas qu'ils
sont un fardeau pour la personne devant
eux aussi ce que je trouve formidable
c'est s'est jamais eu une carrière un
métier je vous dirais aussi gratifiant
que québec ait les syndicats poursuivent
les négociations pour faire en sorte que
même au terme de cette pandémie le
salaire des préposés demeure
à 26 dollars dollars ici david gentilles
et radio canada
mon frère